it's so far from what is you know
acceptable human behavior what she did
in the last few weeks and I think the
biggest mystery of the story is not why
Michelle Carter did what she did but
what Michelle Carter thought she was
doing that was a clip from the HBO
documentary I love you now die about
Michelle Carter the woman convicted of
manslaughter for urging her boyfriend to
kill himself it's one of a pair of
acclaimed documentaries appearing on HBO
this year from director Aaron Lee Carr
and the 31 year-old filmmaker has also
published her first book CBS this
morning co-anchor Anthony Mason recently
talked to Carr about it Anthony good
morning good morning all that you leave
behind his car's memoir of her
relationship with her father who died
four years ago it's also a story about a
family inheritance both good and bad
this is my dad at the White House he has
a press credential he's wearing the
worst time I've seen Erin Leigh Carr's
father the journalist David Carr wrote
to her often she kept everything as a
young person instead of getting it
laminated I just taped the entire thing
with like scotch tape it's a list of the
reasons why he loves me this letter from
her dad came on her 21st birthday called
me dolly dolly do you have any idea how
much I adore and think of you you are a
fundamental joy of my life there's so
much to like about who we were becoming
that it makes for a very long list you
are smart and getting smarter you are
afraid of very few things what did you
think when you got that I thought it was
so special yeah
five years later when she was 26 David
Carr collapsed on the floor of the New
York Times and died from complications
related to lung cancer he was just 58
it's very weird to see like September
8th 1956 to February 12 2015 like that
doesn't make any sense to me I mean
there's an ending to it yeah we've had
reporters they're reporting on genocide
after genocide a beloved media columnist
at The Times car was a mentor to many
including his daughter he helped launch
her career as a documentary filmmaker he
described being David Carr's daughter as
kind of a blessing and and a bit of a
curse he wrote to me you are a car and
that is a wonderous complicated
inheritance what do you do with that you
know I love the good stuff which were
his emails his advice gossiping about
media watching movies thinking about
things those things outweigh the
complicating factors for me which it
would be his intensity his harshness the
expectations he had for me the reward
for achievement is a hunger for more car
would write to his daughter a blessing
that lives inside a curse another curse
in cars life as he detailed in his
memoir the night of the gun he was an
addict
we don't think of proper New York Times
journalists as having crack addictions
and so when I think about my dad's life
as a former drug addict and alcoholic it
really spooked me when he got sober by
and large part to take care of my twin
sister and I'm because my mother was
gone she was not there the stakes were
huge in writing her memoir of their
relationship all that you leave behind
Aaron Lee Carr knew she had to be
equally honest which meant you had to
confront your own alcoholism right you
have to be ready to write about
something like that
I don't I don't know if I'm ever truly
ready for the things that I start to do
yeah I think that we have like a family
code that says move towards fear you
know what I mean do something that makes
you nervous every single day it turned
out Carr writes that alcoholism and
ongoing struggles with booze were some
of the many traits that I shared with my
father
you're dead talk to you about this a lot
but he kind of let me figure it out and
fall down and if I really asked for help
you know he would return my phone call
he would bring me to a meeting but he
knew that only a person can only get and
stay sober for themselves right around
the time that your dad died you were
going through a relapse
yes he was my sober role model and the
fact that he died so early it was so
jarring I had so many questions for him
car rights how do I live sober why were
you so hard on me why were you so hard
on yourself what was the most difficult
one of those for you
Who am I without you mm-hmm I think that
it's so painful to try to figure this
out without him
your father casted a giant shadow when
that shadow passed an effect where were
you
you know the shadow still there I think
that there is a deep and resounding love
for David Carr and we sit here four
years later and I feel very grateful for
the the spell sort of he cast I mean for
a lot of people the shadow would consume
them but I choose to embrace it in
writing her story Aaron Lee car went
back to the nearly 2000 notes emails and
texts her father had sent her I think
that the book is is an exploration of
like me continuing to talk to him yeah
did you discover you can still talk to
him I think on his birthday I can hear
him one year when I was in college I
forgot his birthday and he lost his mind
and he he just said like the most that
is the most hurtful thing you could ever
do to forget about me and so now every
year on his birthday I'm like I remember
it's your birthday I'm sorry I'm
laughing now so I'm not crying I don't I
don't know if he's really there that's
just like kind of my imagination because
I've studied him so much mm-hmm I know
he's there
and he'd be really proud of what she's
accomplished as you mentioned there was
one documentary we saw clip from earlier
on the other one is at the heart of gold
inside the USA Gymnastics scandal both
of those are on HBO they're they're
pretty extraordinary and Aaron lead car
by the way is now going on for years
nearly four years sober so good for her
yeah yeah thanks it's a pretty
extraordinary book I mean we all have
complicated relationships with our
parents it's particularly complicated
and it's it's a remarkable story of how
she's navigated the good and the bad but
so much that I think people can relate
to if you have a relationship with your
father that is strong it's powerful
yeah I already was near to you because
you in both directions
and at a moment of silence there though
in the interview where she is where
she's pausing and considering yes yeah
through grief too when you have a father
who was such a beloved public figure
just adds this complexity to the whole
thing so just tremendously courageous
for her yes it is good to have you here
Anthony nice to be here